it is a good morning isn't it there is i
think for many people
light at the end of the tunnel and just
in terms of the road map we do
understand of course there are always
differences of opinion
around the cabinet room table different
ministers have have different emphases
this roadmap feels like it does have an
awful lot of influence uh from yourself
from the department of health i mean
this is pretty much what you were
looking for wasn't it
well you would expect the department for
health to have an impact
on the road map for coming out of a
pandemic but actually there was
remarkable levels of unanimity in
government of course um you know it's
totally normal to have debates
in this case largely around the details
because we're all absolutely determined
to come out of this as fast as safely
possible
but no faster and the the safety is
important
and we're determined as the prime
minister puts it that this
should be irreversible that is the goal
and then it's then it's a judgment about
how how much we can lift at what moment
but it's not just a judgment for us it's
actually on
everyone and this is one of the points i
want to stress is that some of
you know this isn't just about choices
the government makes
it's actually about how everybody
responds and pulls together
so for now it is so important that
people stick to the existing rules
we can see the light at the end of the
tunnel and the best way to get there is
for everybody to
keep abiding by the rules as they are in
very very large part
and then as we release things
we need to move at that pace because
that is the that is what we expect to be
the safe way to get out of this as fast
as we can
as we roll out the vaccine program
because all of this is only possible
because of that rollout
indeed and i want to kind of quiz you a
little bit more deeply about the the
vaccine efficacy because great data
from chris witte yesterday i think
plenty of people will have stand up
straight at that point
but in terms of the the pace of
relaxation it strikes me
you heard from steve baker just a moment
ago you know he could demanding that
perhaps we could move quicker
under the scheme under the roadmap as
announced it doesn't look like actually
there
is any scope from moving any quicker
because of that that five-week gap
between the steps
well that's right it's very very
important that we can see the impact
of one step before taking the next
step and now there are some
there's a um there's just a vital need
to keep
watching the data and for all of us
and i mean everybody watching and the
whole of society
to stick with this plan you know we want
to be able to hit those milestones
but we'll be vigilant and watch what's
happening to make sure
it's safe to make each move and the
prime minister set out the four tests
that we will
apply before announcing that each move
can go ahead but of course we want to
make the moves at the
at the dates that are set out but it's
on
all of us to make sure that we can by
continuing to follow the rules between
now and then as the vaccine rollout
continues and as the as the really
really positive impact of those vaccines
takes effect
this is on all of us a key aspect of
this is of course
moving out on a national rather than a
regional basis do you think people like
steve baker
will ultimately accept that i understand
the rationale for it but
you know for example if we saw cases
rising in and around
london meaning that you know people in
devon and cornwall
couldn't see restrictions relaxed in
their area
do you think that people first of all in
devon cornwall would accept that
whether people in your party would
accept that well we have
we have seen actually the the the rates
went up right across the country and
then
in this this national lockdown have been
coming down
right across the country more so than
previously actually
now there are some parts of the country
very small targeted areas where we find
new variants that we're worried about
the new variants that might not
be dealt with in the same way by the
vaccine and we've put in particular
measures in those
localized areas for instance some around
around bristol around woking
uh around sefton in in merseyside
um but that's the very much the
exception
the goal here is that we all move
together across england and
nicolas surgeon's setting out the path
for
scotland and the welsh and north nile
irish administrations will set out their
path
but essentially across england a
national approach we think is the right
one yeah
clearly it does feel that those variants
may well be
at the stumbling point or at least the
point that they may result in the
the pause button being hit i'm just
wondering what the government's modeling
is telling us what this
this kind of road map the relaxation
will do as regards
the south african variant the brazilian
variant
well the good news is that the number of
new variant cases we're finding
across the whole uk is falling and has
fallen quite sharply over the last
month um and in the last um
a week or so there were just over a
dozen
new cases which is far smaller than we
were seeing
even a couple of weeks ago so the extra
measures that we're taking at the border
are working
and also the lower case rate makes it
much less
likely that there'll be new variants
here because new variants tend to
arrive when you've got an area that's
got a very high case rate and the
virus is trying to escape from the
immunity that people are getting
naturally now we need to do continued
work
to understand how effective the vaccines
are against these new variants we now
know that the vaccines are extremely
effective
in the real world uh in the uk right now
against the against the main variant
here the so-called kent therian that is
what
is you know the vast vast majority of
cases here are
but we do have to protect against these
new variants and that is a big challenge
one of the reviews announced yesterday
is a review into international travel
and that review will be informed by the
evidence that we're currently collecting
on the impact of the vaccine
on these the so-called south africa and
brazil new variants if the vaccine works
well against them
then we can be much more relaxed about
international travel
if the vaccine doesn't work against them
then
that will be much much more difficult
just in terms of
we mentioned it before fantastic data in
terms of vaccine efficacy and
you and i spoke a few weeks ago and
there was a hint already at that point
that there was data
confirming that do we have enough
information yet on what effect the
vaccines are having on transmissibility
well the evidence published by public
health england yesterday
demonstrate that there is a reduction
of around 70 percent in
your chance of catching the virus and
the there's obviously link from that to
transmissibility
if you don't have them uh the virus then
you can't
easily transmit it obviously um the
and and then an even bigger impact in
terms of
death and hospitalization so these are
this is a really really good result you
know
i i had confidence that we'd get a
vaccine
i have huge confidence in the nhs to
roll out the vaccine
and it's wonderful to see the effect
of the vaccine saving lives in the uk
right now not just in a lab not just in
a trial
but the vaccines are saving lives right
now
and you can see the result in the real
world data as well
because if you look at the number of
people who are dying each day
that number is falling sharply it's
actually
falling more sharply than it was even a
couple of weeks ago
so the halving rate of deaths
is accelerating and
that's despite the fact that the halving
rate of hospital admissions
is holding steady so this is real world
information showing that the vaccines
are working to save lives in the uk
right now and that obviously is
incredibly encouraging
yeah very encouraging indeed can we talk
about business and we've obviously heard
a number of times
the government stands ready to do
whatever it takes to to protect
livelihoods and businesses of course the
roadmap published
yesterday sets out our routes all the
way to the to the tail end of june
you know if i'm a small medium sized
business owner this morning it wouldn't
be daft for me would it to assume that
furlough business rates relief is going
to be extended
till the end of june as well well you
tempt me
uh no but the um that's very much a
matter for the chancellor
and it is we could do with hearing from
them right now couldn't we know that
we've had the road map i understand the
budget is in a week's time and i see you
smiling there but you know there may be
will be business owners watching this or
perhaps
not so sanguine about the fact they have
to wait another seven days to know
well look i understand that and coming
from a small business background myself
i
entirely understand the impact of this
on small businesses and it's been
devastating for some and difficult
for most and the the level of economic
support that the government's put in is
both unprecedented and bigger than
almost anywhere else in the world
and the chancellor is going to set out
more details
next week can we dwell for a second
health secretary
the the judgement handed down by the
high court last week and and
a lot of ground has been gone over i'm
not asking you for an apology i'm not
asking whether or not
you're going to resign i do think it's
worthwhile asking but whether you
understand why there are
quite so many people concerned about the
procurement process
there was a there is an opaque quality
to it
a number of contracts have been awarded
to people that you
and others within government have
personal relationships of some form or
another with
do you understand why and i get the
rationale for why you had to operate in
this way i understand your position
but do you also understand that perhaps
in the not too distant future people
would like to know
that all of those contracts have been
awarded in a proper way would you
be mine would you be accepting of the
possibility of
an independent inquiry getting the
transparency on your department that a
lot of people are after
well that transparency is there so the
good news is that
um the there already has been an inquiry
into this by the national audit office
and they published their results which
found that there wasn't a problem with
any of the
individual contracts and indeed this
court case wasn't about the individual
contract also refused to rule out
criminal abuse
if i just answered the question you ask
for transparency
the only reason that people know about
these contracts
is because of the transparency rules
that we rightly have in place
and because we published all of the
details now we published them
around on average a couple of weeks late
and and that's what the court case was
about um but it wasn't about the
substance
of the contract because that's already
been looked into in by the national
audit office
and all of them have stood up to
scrutiny now
people then say but hold on some people
you knew what contracts
well are you saying that if you know a
minister then you shouldn't be allowed
to have contracts
so i didn't know perhaps that but
perhaps there might need to be a little
bit more scrutiny
well there's been enormous amounts of
scrutiny and as
you know as this conversation attests
and the reason that the
we can have this discussion is because
we have that transparency
and the contracts in question i didn't
have uh
personal involvement in the signing of
the
individual contracts but sure what i did
do
is make sure that my team were given all
the support they could
to buy ppe to save lives and you know we
as you say we have been through this and
i think you know the
the argument that i'm making is the
argument that
not only anybody in my position would
have uh
would have made and would have done but
also it's what the public expect
right they'd expect me as health
secretary to ensure my team had all the
support they
possibly can i mean the judge to the
judge and the judge in the case said
that the history of these proceedings is
unedifying the lion's share of the blame
lies with the secretary of state lies
with you
200 000 pounds was spent on legal fees
for a case that didn't need to happen
because you could have simply said
yes we were in breach well it's
absolutely true that the case didn't
need to happen
because it was uh not a you know it
hasn't had any material impact so
you'll have to ask the people who
brought the case why they did that
um the um to get you to get you to
accept that you were in breach
as the judge said i have no doubt the
claim has speeded up compliance
but we we accept we accepted
in full that these things were published
a fortnight late that isn't in dispute
uh what we argued was it was we argued a
public interest defense
it's in the national interest that we
did what we did
and my team who are an amazing group of
people
who worked incredibly hard to save lives
and that's what we do in the health
department
and and sure you know if we weren't able
to put the paperwork in
on time you know in normal times of
course we put the paperwork in on time
but in the middle of a global pandemic
you don't so you can you know you can
ask me as many questions you'd like
you're not going to change my view
and if i had my time again absolutely
i'd do exactly the same thing
exactly the same thing even if it led to
this conversation
because what i care about is making sure
that people have the protection they
need
and i care deeply about the staff of the
nhs
and the staff who work in social care
and i care deeply that they have
everything they need
and it was really tough but there wasn't
a national shortage at any point there
were difficulties in individual areas
but there was never a national shortage
and that's because of the work that my
team did and i'm very
very proud of them